Right. Yes, guys. Welcome back. So,
this is a little psychological video on
what's been going on. So, obviously, you
seen in the last few videos that we've
been taking a few losses. Again, we're
going down a little bit of a bumpy road.
However, you need to know these are the
points of where you actually grow the
most as a trader. So, whereas other
people would potentially be stressing.
So, I'm not saying in this situation
right now, but when you're actually
taking losses, they may be stressing and
thinking, damn, like I'm taking a lot of
losses here. I'm just eating [__] But
realistically, you have to realize
you're the one clicking the button. It's
not someone else's fault. It's not the
market's fault. It's your fault. And
once you realize that, you know, then
you actually start taking accountability
for the [__] trades you take. And on
Friday, there were two avoidable losses
that I could have taken. However, I took
the trades at the time thinking that,
you know, this is this is valid. This is
something I'm happy with taking and then
I take it. And the same thing happened
on Monday. Monday again, you know, the
setup was clean, but it was outside of
my trading time by around 30 seconds.
So, still again another way that I've
broken my rules. And then today as well,
we took a trade which actually went and
hit TP. We got stopped out and it went
lower than on our stop loss by one point
and then it went to TP. However, I don't
care because I shouldn't have even been
in that trade in the first place. So
once you realize these things guys, you
know, it really shifts your mind to
think that you need to sort your [__]
out. And once you do that, you then go
back and you actually think, how bad do
I really want this? Do you have the
are you man enough to admit to your
mistakes? Because not a lot of people
can admit to their mistakes. They'll
either just try run away from them or
pretend that they're not even there or
don't even realize that they're even
there. So once you actually figure out
that, okay, I've made a few mistakes. I
realized what's gone wrong. Now I need
to try and fix this. So then that's
where the building blocks start to
happen. And I've been in this situation
so many times. And this isn't even
major. I just thought I'd make a video
on this. Like, I'm completely fine. I'm
going on in my day like I'm on a 20
trade winning streak. I don't give a
[__] bro. And I know that some of these
trades have been losing because of me.
When it's the market just not playing
out, then that's obviously different.
Then, you know, you just got to like
take it on the chin. But when you're
making those mistakes, you got to
knuckle them down. Make sure that [__]
doesn't happen. And how do you do that?
First you start with realizing the
problem, taking accountability, then
going back behind the scenes and
approving on that [__] And that's
exactly what I'm doing. So the VIP room
know what's going on. If you want to get
involved, then obviously the link in
bio. And it is a great community. We're
all going through this together. We're
going through the ups, we're going
through the downs. And that's the thing
about the community. It's not you come
in and you're guaranteed to make 10
grand in your first [__] day. No, it
isn't. Although we have had people
getting paid out four, five figures in
the space of a week to a month, that's
not the whole point. The whole point is
that you come in to learn to trade and
be able to go through the highs and the
lows. Because if you're by yourself and
you go through these bad losing streaks,
this is where really bad
or just negative thoughts go in your
head, then you start taking really bad
decisions. Like right now, we can see.
All right. So, I was actually looking
for shorts right here. This is PM
session. We've just finished the PM
macro. Absolutely zero trades. I was
actually looking for a short. Price is
running down lower. But would I take a
trade now? No, I wouldn't. One, we're
outside of macro. Two, my trade didn't
present. Three, I'm done for the day,
man. I'm done for the day. Like, I don't
care if price runs. I've seen it run so
many times and I don't care.
Like you got to realize guys that these
things are going to happen. It's all
part of being a trader. Nothing is
guaranteed. And like one of the guys in
the VIP VIP room VIP VIP room said that
you know if you don't take risks then
like you're not living life on the edge
then you're just taking up space. And I
know I just kind of waffle but like
just don't be you can't be average bro
and just be like settle for less. I
don't mean settle for less. Settle for,
you know, somewhere where your life is
just stable each day. Every day is a new
challenge and that's what I love about
it. So these things, they teach you so
many life skills and I'm able to go
through that with the group and that's
the best thing about it. It's not like
somewhere where I'm claiming that I have
10 million in payouts. Anyone who's
doing that and guaranteeing you 100% win
rate, that's not how it is. I will teach
you how to properly trade and analyze
the markets and be consistently
profitable. But that comes with also,
you know, getting to know each other
onetoone and going through these ups and
downs of trading. And I've been through
there through the lows of the lows to
the highs of the highs. I'm telling you
boys, when I first started trading at
16, I lost around 10k GBP. That's
probably like $12,000.
and at 16 years old like no who what
16-year-old even has 10k to lose. So I
lost all of that and then eventually you
know now made it all back and I'm
consistently profitable but these losing
streaks do happen and we literally went
through one in September and what
happened we then went on a eight trade
winning streak made it all back plus
profit got payouts got paid out around
nearly 10k from that point. Now again,
we're going through a little losing
streak. Um, and again, I'm not expecting
the same thing to happen where I go on a
eight trade winning streak, but this
losing streak could have been avoided
and I know that. So, this isn't even a
losing streak. That's part of the
probabilities. So, that's why I'm now
expecting to lose tomorrow and maybe
I'll lose the day after that and maybe
I'll lose the day after that. But, as
long as it's in my plan, then I'm happy.
But if I'm losing trades based off just
stupidity, that's where we've got a
problem. like probabilities. It's not um
you know out of a thousand days at least
one of them you're going to slip up. Do
you know what I'm saying? But then out
of a thousand days, you know, at least
one of them you're going to have a
really good day and you're going to have
a really bad day. So you got to take
these things into consideration and know
these things are normal. And that's
enough of my waffle. So I hope you guys
have enjoyed my little rant session. I'm
feeling better to be fair. And uh let's
see what we get tomorrow.